china's parliament has backed the
communist party's plan to tighten
control of hong kong
by overhauling the city's electoral
system the national people's congress
overwhelmingly passed the resolution
that grants beijing
veto power over candidates to ensure
that the city is governed by
quote patriots critics say these changes
will effectively eliminate all remaining
opposition and they're calling it a
final nail in the coffin
of hong kong's democracy movement
and let's go right to our correspondent
in hong kong afibi kung
is standing by for us there hi phoebe
what will this new electoral system mean
for the people of hong kong
beijing's has took a controversial path
to uh
push for the electoral reform by
bypassing hong kong's local scrutiny
and uh passing the resolution in beijing
and under the new reform
it will give greater power to the
electoral committee
which is largely stacked with probation
figures
to screen the candidates and decide some
of the winners in the local elections in
the future so under the new proposal
that electoral committee which is
originally only responsible for picking
chief executive in hong kong but in the
future
they will also be responsible for
screening
some of the candidates and be part of
the legislature
in the hong kong the so-called mini
parliament in hong kong
so under the new threshold it is
expected that it will be much more
difficult
opposition can for merely be the
candidates of the chief executive
election
and also a new factory mechanism and
a sensor a censoring committee will be
set up to uh
to screen the candidates for local
legislature and uh only allow those who
are what what is called as patriots by
beijing to run for elections in the
future
those are some pretty serious changes
phoebe and we mentioned the critics say
this is
essentially the final nail on the coffin
of democracy in hong kong
is it
well for the opposition came on the
ground they agree that
this new proposal means that they won't
have any room
for genuine election and democracy in
hong kong
despite the fact that hong kong has
the food interest in the future they are
even more pessimistic of the room for
running for any kind of
campaign and um even though our people
are critical of the proposal but
now uh descent are largely silenced
because of the national security law
many of the
opposition figures already jailed or
detained so
we they they are not likely to voice any
kind of opposition within the
the political position and outside or
even on the streets
so um for them is a pretty doomed like
for their political career to
do to be carry on in any kind of form in
the future in hong kong
our correspondent phoebe kong with the
very latest there thank you so much
you